welcome to the show today we're going to
talk about what happens when a person
sells their soul it never works out for
them we should have learned that by now
throughout human history certainly it
doesn't work out in the long run but
even in the even in the short run it
doesn't work an actress was bragging
this week about having killed her child
bragging that it helped her career in
Hollywood she traded in her baby she
traded in her soul for a career but
let's see how that actually worked out
for her I think there's a lot to be
learned for it from it all so five
headlines including the supposedly
controversial execution of Nathaniel
Woods last night he was executed for the
killing of three police officers now his
supporters say that this is wrong he
should have been executed because he
didn't pull the trigger but should that
actually make a difference we'll talk
about that
and your emails including one of an
email about the new Taylor Swift song I
don't know if you've heard this one or
seen the video but it's absurdly dumb
even by her standards and it illustrates
that's very anti man song and it
illustrates how feminists see men which
is they see us like cartoon villains so
we'll talk about that and oh yeah
MSNBC there's a segment on MSNBC I'm
going to canceling MSNBC today finally
should have done it long ago because
they aired what may be the dumbest
segment ever to make its way onto cable
news and I understand what a statement
that is but I think I can back it up and
we'll get to all of that coming up now
we spoke yesterday about the
pro-abortion protesters in DC losing
their minds over a case of that if
decided the right way which is against
them would simply result in abortion
clinics having to follow the same
regulations that any other medical
clinic has to follow having to have
omitting privileges at a local hospital
in case there's a medical emergency
which does happen happens hundreds of
times across the country every single
year in abortions not surprising given
what the with the abortion procedure
entails but but but that's we're told we
can't have those kinds of regulations
because as we talked about yesterday
pro-abortion people
they don't take their own propaganda
seriously they say abortion is
healthcare yet they don't want the law
to regulate it as health care now they
want they're all they're all about all
the other regulations for every other
medical clinic but not not for abortion
clinics abortion abortion proponents
they want to have their abortion cake
and eat it too they want to present
child murder as a legitimate medical
procedure while reserving the right to
go into spasms of fury and anger
if anyone proposes a law that actually
treats abortion as a legitimate medical
procedure that's because abortion for
them is not actually medicinal despite
what they say it's sacramental its
religious senator gillibrand was was she
was on on cable news last week and she
tied abortion to religious freedom it's
a matter of religious freedom that women
should be able to kill their kids well
she was actually telling the truth it is
religious you know no law no policy no
regulation or limitation can get within
a thousand miles of this sacred ritual
they're going to defend unlimited
abortion with the same satanic
enthusiasm that the Aztecs defended
their temples of of human sacrifice it's
the same sort of same sort of energy
that you see all decency and dignity
goes out the window because the idol has
to be protected at all costs and that's
what we've been witnessing in DC this
week speaking of dignity going out the
window I played a few clips yesterday of
the rally including various speakers
getting up there and screaming about
abortion including the infamous one of
Chuck Schumer threatening the
conservative justices by name to try to
intimidate them into deciding the case
the way that he wants but there's one
clip I didn't play because I hadn't seen
it before the show aired and I'm gonna
play it now because there's an important
and I think quite sad quite tragic truth
to be found here not in what's being
said but I'm gonna play it for this is
the actress Busy Philipps
here she is
speaking screaming actually about her
abortion among well other things sitting
in Los Angeles in my beautiful office of
my own late-night talk show soon I would
be driving my hybrid car to my beautiful
mom to kiss my two beautiful and healthy
children and my husband who had taken
the year off to parents so I could focus
on my career because because because I
was allowed bodily autonomy at fifteen I
will not be shamed into being quiet
we will not be shamed into being quiet
never again yeah III I don't even know
where to begin I I do believe that maybe
the first time in history that yeast
effect infections have gotten applause
you think that's ever happened before
someone uses a yeast infection as an
applause line she says she's never gonna
stop talking about her East infections
which also that may be the first time in
history that that sentence has ever been
uttered I'll never stop talking about my
yeast infections and what other context
would anyone have ever said that now it
raises the question of many questions a
race but but one question is very simple
why are you not gonna stop talking about
it exactly what's what's the reason for
that why are you talking about it to
begin with what's your
factions have to do with anything right
now and why would you be proud of them
and again what do they have to do with
abortion I mean whether abortion rights
are rights or not how does your yeast
infection factor into it that's like if
somebody was up giving a speech at a gun
rights rally and and suddenly said I
have the right to bear arms also I have
toe fungus
I have toe fungus and I will never stop
talking about my fungus it is my fungus
but this is the mark of a of a modern
feminist that she loves to speak in
graphic terms about her body and it's
functions and she also wants you to know
that all of the things she's telling you
which you didn't ask to hear about and
certainly don't want to hear about are
none of your business
now as for the abortion the relevant
portion of this we're gonna get to that
in just a minute but first let me tell
you about legacy box you know it's it's
I know as a parent myself you have so
many memories right you have so many
experiences with your kids and one thing
that that troubles me I've realized that
my memory is very is very bad so I
forget things very quickly and now III
think to myself like how many great
moments have I already forgotten that
I've had as a family and with my kids
well that's where legacy box comes in
it's a way of preserving all those
memories so you don't forget about them
so that you always have them legacy box
is a way for you to easily and
affordably digitally preserve your past
so you have those memories there the
process from start to finish it's so
easy you just you just pack up
everything and send it over you know
we're talking about old pictures and and
VHS tapes whatever you have you send it
over very easy process to the team
digitizes everything by hand and then
you receive perfectly preserved digital
copy copies on a thumb thumb drive a DVD
or the cloud however you know whatever's
most convenient for you however you want
it and then you have it there you can
watch it you can share it you can enjoy
it you can go back and access those
memories if you don't have them in your
head anymore especially plus they keep
you up
with regular email updates throughout
the digitizing process legacy box is the
world's largest digitizer of home movies
and photos and has helped over 750,000
families digitally preserve their past
so get started preserving your past
today go to legacy box.com slash Walsh
to get an incredible 40 percent off your
first order
but today take advantage of this
exclusive offer and you can send in when
you're ready go to legacy box.com slash
Walsh and save 40 percent
you're saving 40% right now if you go to
legacy box.com slash Walsh while
supplies last
okay Busy Philipps says that she's happy
that she had her abortion and killed her
offspring her child because it enabled
her to have a wonderful career in a talk
show but and you know and I'm not even
trying to insult her here not that I can
be blamed for insulting such a vile
grotesque excuse for a human being but
that's not even my point that's not my
point in pointing out that you know the
talk show she said that she has that
made the abortion worth it the talk show
has been cancelled
it's canceled after one season and her
acting career let's take a look at her
IMDB page she had she you know let's
take a look at the things she's had
roles in often bit roles and I'm going
down this the unbreakable kimmy schmitt
she appeared in some episodes of that a
show called camping she had a few
voiceover roles in American Dad drunk
history something called grizzly bear
losing all sense the new girl cougar
town there's I think I recognize that
one okay made in Cleveland these are all
just a lot of these just one episode it
looks like that she appeared in don't
trust the B word in apartment 23 I was
it was a show that was on it looks like
for one year and she was on for one
episode and I'm just going down I'm
trying to find something that would be
How I Met Your Mother she did an episode
of that and just a lot of stuff like
that white chicks she was in the movie
white chicks okay there's one I remember
that movie cinematic masterpiece is my
point
she sold her soul killed her child and
this is what she got out of it a
cancelled talk show a skit on drunk
history a voiceover on the reef to high
tide now look of course even if she had
five Academy Award wins and and her
filmography was chock-full of of film
classics it still wouldn't make the
abortion worth it nothing could ever
justify killing a child no earthly
reward no professional achievement or
accomplishment could vindicate that of
course but it just shows you the tragic
absurdity of this idea that a woman
should sacrifice literally sacrifice her
children and her family for a career
because Busy Philipps did that and she
wants us to believe that it was all
worth it and and her career may be
profitable maybe she's made some money I
would believe that but nobody's gonna
remember anything this woman has done in
her career so far nobody remembers it
now
and this somehow is considered the noble
choice to throw out motherhood for this
for this you know GK Chesterton he had a
great quote where he talks about in our
professional lives not just women men
too we are the same thing to everyone in
that we fill a certain role we do a
certain thing and in that role and our
jobs when we're clocked in that's what
we are to everybody no matter what you
do I mean even if you're the president
United States well you're the president
you knighted States that's that's what
you are to everybody but as parents you
know rather than being the same thing to
everybody we are everything to someone
or to a few people depending how many
kids you have and he points out that
especially
with women this idea that the latter
role where you're everything to someone
everything to your children the idea
that that's narrower and more confining
and less noble and less worthwhile is is
ludicrous it's a lie it's one of the
worst lies that modern culture tells our
role as parents that role much more than
our role in our job or Busy Philipps
role in made in Cleveland is a dynamic
versatile thing something that will will
make a lasting difference a lasting
impact something that will leave a
legacy
speaking of legacies now that's not to
say that your job is unimportant and
some jobs are more important than others
some people some jobs are basically are
basically completely unimportant except
for I mean even in a completely
frivolous an unimportant job if you have
a family that that actually lends import
to that job it gives it meaning because
at least you're there and you're doing
this for your family so the meaning
comes from that see the meaning springs
forth from that role as a parent as a
husband as a wife a mother if all you
have is your job to find meaning in well
that ultimately is going to feel like
and it is going to be in many ways a
meaningless life the fact is that
whatever you do for a living
probably you know you can leave that job
and be replaced easily and nobody will
remember what you did maybe a few
exceptions to this there are a few
people across the world who are
exceptions this but but almost all of us
whatever we do for a living matter how
important we might think it is
you can leave eventually you will leave
you'll be just replaced by somebody your
company whoever you work for they're
gonna find someone to fill in that role
and they're gonna move forward and and
you know no one's gonna make maybe if
you were employee of the month or
something well you get your plaque on
the wall and so you'll and that's all
you'll be now is just that picture on
the wall if that but you get replaced
and it doesn't matter now you leave your
role as parent you're not
be easily replace in fact you cannot be
replaced at all not fully and that loss
you know you think of a father who
abandons its children the father works
at a job leaves the job who cares
he'll be replaced no one's gonna care
remember leaves his kids though that's
gonna leave a hole in those kids lives
forever that they're never gonna fully
get over now I mean look at me I write I
write articles I do podcasts there are a
million people who do the same thing a
million podcasts out there nobody's
gonna remember this segment that I'm
doing right now by the end of by the
time this is over you probably will
forgot to buy it by the end of today
you'll probably have forgotten it
someone's gonna remember it next week
even tomorrow probably you know this
show that I'm doing it could could could
disappear but the entire show then it
could disappear and and some of you
would care for 10 minutes some of you
would celebrate but even that
celebration would wouldn't last long and
then you just move on with your lives
right because what I into you is maybe
I'm something to you hopefully but I
could be replaced with somebody else
you'll find whatever role I play in your
life as a viewer you'll find someone
else to fill that role not like that for
my kids so you know that that's that's
what really makes a difference that
what's that's what makes an impact so
when we encourage people especially
women and they're the mains one main
ones who are encouraged to do this to
subordinate Parenthood and for women to
subordinate motherhood beneath the
Almighty career when we encourage them
even to kill to murder in order to
escape motherhood so they can focus on
their career we are encouraging
encouraging them to put the more
important thing the more beautiful thing
the more sacred thing below the less
important and less beautiful thing and
that makes no sense and you know what
else it also very clearly does not lead
to joy does not lead to fulfillment does
not lead to happiness I said this
yesterday you know look at Busy Philipps
they're screaming about her yeast
infection the
she strike you as a joyful person does
she strike you as someone who is
fulfilled in her life and happy about
what she's doing and feels confident
about it no because I tell you if you
feel confident about your life choices
you don't get on a behind a microphone
on a stage and scream about them tried
to justify them if you feel confident in
them now she went looking for that
meaning and that joy in in the career
and clearly has not found it which is
which is shocking you know I'm shocked
that she can't find meaning and joy in
her role as a Karen in white chicks
she actually played a woman named Karen
in white chicks that's what it says in
IMDB you know one other thing here that
I was thinking about think about the
message that this sends and this is all
very intentional of course but think
about the message of this sentence to
young young women who are pregnant when
you've got these Hollywood actresses
pro-abortion people Democrats people in
the media and Hollywood saying that
according to Busy Philipps you know she
got all of this all of these wonderful
things she got because emphasizing
because because because of her abortion
so think about the effect that has on a
if there's a young pregnant woman he was
watching TV watching the news and she
sees that hears that and she doesn't
need to see it there I mean she's
getting that message everywhere and
certainly if she goes to the Planned
Parenthood clinic
that's the message she's gonna get the
only way for you as a woman a pregnant
woman the only way for you to have
success in life is to kill your shot you
have to reject motherhood you have to
reject this profound power that you have
to bring new life into the world you
have to reject that through literally
throw it in the garbage if you want to
have success in life this
this whole part this whole facet of
womanhood the most spectacular facet of
it the reject it throw it out if you
want to have success you can't have you
can't have both you as a woman you
cannot have both you got to choose one
of the other success in life or
motherhood
that's the message as I said completely
intentional trying to scare women into
getting abortions and it's not even true
actually Busy Philipps
traded in her child for her worthless
stupid career making horrible movies
that nobody cares about or will ever
remember but she didn't even she didn't
even need to do that there are plenty of
women who have kids are loving mothers
and have also you know gone out into the
world and and and they do other things
as well maybe it's a job maybe it's a
you know they have to have a there
another vocation as well and and so they
have that kind of success and they can
express maybe of you know women who are
very artistic I think my wife is great
my wife is a very skilled person's a
skilled mother but she's got other
skills as well that are not directly
tied to to motherhood she's found ways
to express those skills as well as being
a great mother so that is possible and
isn't the empowering thing to say to a
woman for empowering women shouldn't we
be saying you can you can do that you
you can be a great mother you don't have
to reject this part of womanhood and you
can also have all that you can have all
of that actually alright we're gonna
move on to headlines here in a moment
but first Super Tuesday has passed and
according to Joe Biden Super Thursday is
also unfortunately over now but you're
still in luck because right now we're
offering 25% off all daily wire
membership plans using coupon code never
socialist it could I just say in defense
of Joe Biden that every day is super
okay that's my motto as an optimist as
you know that I am so if you go to daily
water membership plans using coupon code
never socials you get twenty five
percent off daily wire
members that's really makes it a super
day for your daily wire members get an
ad-free website experience access to all
of our live broadcast and show library
including the Matt Walsh show the full
three hours the Ben Shapiro show access
to the mailbag exclusive election
insight op-eds from ben shapiro daily
wire members also get to ask questions
when we have these these conversations
you could take part in the in the you
know AMA discussions that we have as
well which are always a lot of fun
along with all this of course you get
the magnificent the irreplaceable the
glorious the beautiful the the super
natural I don't know I'm grasping at
straws for adjectives here anyway the
left is tears tumblr it's just it's a
plastic cup let's be honest but it's
it's really great and you can you know
drink coffee out of it and if you
haven't already you can download the
daily water app so you get all of our
great content on the go again that's 25%
off daily wired memberships for all
plans using coupon code never socialist
all right let's go to five headlines
number one despite protests from
celebrities and media people and Kim
Kardashian etc etc Alabama executed in
Sanya woods last night his supporters
said that he shouldn't have been
executed because even though he was
convicted of killing three police
officers he actually did not pull the
trigger what what happened was the three
of the police officers were storming the
crack house where innocent old Nathaniel
woods was was and they were shot in the
process well we also know that Nathaniel
woods it's not just that his actions led
to these police officers being killed
although that's true also but he also
directly told the gunman to go and kill
the police officers and then he did and
they're dead the idea that that makes
him less culpable is asinine in my view
it's no different really from a woman
who goes to a hitman and says kill my
husband okay she's not wielding the
murder weapon but obviously she's just
as culpable if not more so than the
Hitman so he was he was executed
ultimately and I would say justice was
served there number two let's go from
justice serve to justice not
this guy D and Riaan Anderson well let's
take a look at what he did last year
watch this video
[Music]
so he's finally been sentenced for that
30 days in jail is what he's getting
now I'm not kidding when I say if I'm
the judge I give him a year in state
prison for that and it's it's it's so
gratuitous and gross and it betrays such
a disregard for common decency and for
other people
that yeah I would throw them in prison
for a year they're spreading germs or
spreading disease you're spreading it
intentionally to someone you don't even
know like someone's gonna buy that ice
cream and feed it to their kids and
you've slobbered all over it just the
the disregard for other people I think
is enough to land him in jail now that's
it I say a year in jail if I was a judge
in the United States under our current
system of course under my dictatorial
theocratic regime it goes without saying
that the punishment we quite harsher and
more just than that what I would do
probably in this circumstance is and I'd
have to look at his prior his prior
convictions and I'd have to look at his
his criminal history when I say criminal
history I mean you know does he lick his
fingers as we talked about is is he a
Michael Bloomberg those sorts so that's
gonna factor in but if this was a
one-time deal it would begin he would
have his tongue amputated of course then
he'd be strapped to the back of a donkey
with a sack over his head and exiled out
into the desert with two jugs of water
and what happens from there happens
number three the Assistant Secretary of
for Health that's a HHS spoke to the
media yesterday with some somewhat
reassuring information on the corona
virus and I also enjoyed this because it
proved prove me right and a lot of the
things I've been saying on the show the
last few days we are still very early in
understanding and all the evidence isn't
there so I want to caveat that but to
set a Grasim foundation the typical
mortality rate for seasonal flu is about
0.1% or 0.15 percent the best estimates
now of the overall mortality rate
for Kovan 19 is somewhere between 0.1
percent and 1%
okay that's lower than you heard
probably in many reports why is this
number one is because many people don't
get sick and don't get tested so
probably four and this is reflects the
overseas experience so probably for
every case there are at least two or
three cases that are not in the
denominator so I just want to sort of
scale that that it's certainly could be
higher than normal flu it probably is
but it's not likely in the range of two
to three percent so our best modeling
again you have a denominator problem and
I want you to understand that that only
the people who are really sick or have
symptoms come in and get tested so based
on is is based on the models we have
right now we estimate the mortality as
0.1 to 1% it is likely not in the range
of 2 to 3% now of course we still take
the virus seriously nobody's saying that
but fortunately the fatality rate isn't
nearly as bad as what's being reported
which you know maybe means they should
stop reporting it may be that the news
should stop saying that the fatality the
mortality rate is 2 or 3 percent because
it's not just a thought number for
reading now from a Daily Mail exclusive
report it says Bill Clinton claims that
his affair with Monica Lewinsky was one
of the things was one of the quote
things I did to manage my anxieties the
former president suggests in an
explosive documentary seen by Daily Mail
TV that he had the fling with the ex
White House intern while he was in
office because it helped with his own
issues bill reveals that at the time he
met Lewinsky the pressure of the job
made him feel like a boxer who had done
30 rounds and he looked at Lewinsky as
something that will take your mind off
it for a while he makes the claim in an
interview featured in the new
documentary series that will air on air
on hulu about his wife Hillary Clinton
called Hillary where the former first
lady in Secretary of State candidly
reveals that in the aftermath of the
scandal the couple underwent painful
marriage counseling
so there you go there's there is the
casual even now at this point the casual
cruelty of Bill Clinton even now these
many years later he's literally
referring to to this to a woman Monica
Lewinsky as a thing it's one of the
things I did she was one of the things I
did to manage anxieties just something
to take my mind off it yes there's a
whole other human being but who cares
him her life was destroyed by it I mean
think about if you're Monica Lewinsky
her whole life is defined by this this
is all she talked about being one thing
to everybody the same thing to everybody
this is who she is that now of course
she's actually a human being and there's
a lot more to her than this but as far
as the public is concerned you say
Monica Lewinsky this is the only thing
that anybody will ever think about and
that's what he did and even now says
that's just something I did for just
took my mind off it
you know could have been this kind of it
could have played ping-pong it's using a
woman and throwing around this is this
is how Bill Clinton operates not a
surprise for someone who's good friends
with Jeffrey Epstein number five finally
Rachel Maddow went to interview a as the
kids would say a very salty Elizabeth
Warren and during the course of the
interview they of course mourned the
fact that we will not have a woman
president if Hillary Clinton can't win
when she gets the nomination and then
you can't get the nomination and neither
can Kamala Harris and neither can Amy
Klobuchar and neither can kirsten
gillibrand
I mean I think part of what's going on
today is that women around the country
are like okay honestly you know it's not
going to be any of them let's get reals
it just is it just that it can't be any
woman ever are we just gonna run you
know white men in their late 70s against
each other both parties and that's all
we can agree to do I think there's a
there's a feeling that your campaign
ending is is very specific to you and it
also feels a little bit like a death
knell in terms of the prospects of
having a woman for president in our
elections oh god please no that can't be
right I mean what I'm talking I know
exactly what you're talking about
I know exactly what you're talking about
this cannot be the right answer no I
understand that this is very sexist for
me to say but I have to say and and
don't take it the wrong way but I don't
give the slightest damn whether we have
a woman president or not and I think
probably Maddow is sensing that most
people don't care and that and that
upset sir but why should we care I care
about having a good president we've had
a lot of bad presidents that's true am I
saying that a woman could never be a
good president no so Ron a good woman
for president and I'll vote for her not
because she's a woman but if she's the
best in the field in my opinion I'll
vote for her but but don't go into this
whole I will never have a woman
president woe is me thing after you know
this this time around we had Elizabeth
Warren to choose from Klobuchar
Gillibrand
Kamala Harris last time Hillary Clinton
put put a woman up there who would make
a good president how about that for for
an idea and people will vote for her but
the simple fact of being a woman and of
course we can we can get into the fact
that these are the same people who say
that gender is relative and is on a
spectrum and it's all fluid and so there
really isn't anything but there is
anything there's no such thing as a
woman or man so that of course makes all
of this all of what they're saying a
self-contradictory anyway okay let's
let's go to your daily cancellation
I've been waiting waiting to do this I
can't wait any longer I think today on a
Friday it seems like a great opportunity
to cancel MSNBC
and it feels good to cancel it not for
political reasons or ideological reasons
but just on the basis of sheer
unadulterated grade-a stupidity in fact
as I said this clip from MSNBC
that I'm going to play might be this
stupidest thing you will ever see on
cable news I know that's a hell of a
statement and I know it has so much
competition and I know that future cable
news segments will try like hell to top
the stupidity of this segment
I know legions of Talking Heads and
cable news anchors in the future will
see this as a challenge and they're
gonna say oh no I could be stupider than
that watch me but I'm telling you I
don't think they can do it I don't think
anyone can do it watch you see it as a
possibility if he wants to spend a
billion bucks beating this guy he could
do it absolutely
somebody tweeted recently that actually
with the money he spent he could have
given every American a million dollars
got it let's put it up a screen it when
I read it tonight on social media it
kind of all became clear
Bloomberg spent five hundred million on
ads u.s. population 327 million don't
tell us if your ahead of us on the math
he could have given each American 1
million dollars and I've had lunch money
left over
it's an incredible way of putting it
it's an incredible way of putting it
it's true it's disturbing it does it
does suggest you know what we're talking
about here which is there's too much
money in politics yeah this this reminds
me of the time that I won 75 bucks on a
scratch-off and so I gave my parents and
all of my siblings $16,000 each the math
checks out no actually I'm not sure that
it does so let's think about this 327
million people 500 million dollars if we
give a million dollars to each person if
we were to line everybody up every all
through it's a line 327 million people
along line them all up and again give
each a million we would run out of money
by person number 501 the first 500
people are lucky so they made out like
bandits everybody else you're out of
luck that's because 327 million times a
million is 327 trillion you would need
327 trillion dollars to give everybody a
million dollars which is shall we say a
little bit more than
five hundred million in reality I you
know with the money that he spent five
hundred million bucks
he could have distributed that between
three hundred twenty seven million
people that's true but it would have
worked out too what about a buck fifty
I'm no math genius myself and so this is
part of the way that I know that this is
so stupid that I I myself in very very
very dumb with math you don't even
understand how dumb I am I don't even
want to tell you the kinds of math
problems that I will use my calculator
for okay I won't even get into it my son
says dad what's two plus two
I say hang on a second let me grab my
phone okay but even I am shocked by the
stupidity of this if you can shock me
with your math stupidity then that
should tell you something
so but no you a dollar fifty a person
for five hundred million dollars
I think Bloomberg could have feasibly
brought bought everybody in America a
box of Tic Tacs
and maybe two gumballs from a gumball
machine now granted that would have been
a better use of his money than all of
these ads for a political campaign that
resulted in him winning American Samoa
and that's it
probably be better off with the tic tacs
and gumballs for everybody but that's
that's all that would have happened now
the person who tweeted this originally
followed it up and she said blah blah
blah math blah blah that sentiment I
relate to blah blah blah math blah blah
that's my argument that I would make to
all of my math teachers in high school
as I would fail the math test
blah blah blah math who needs it anyway
blah blah blah math blah blah people are
telling me my numbers are wrong but the
point still stands he could easily
afford to give everyone a million
dollars and literally never notice well
no I think he would notice because again
a million dollars each person would cost
him three hundred twenty seven trillion
dollars he's worth sixty billion so so
if he were to distribute his entire net
worth among the entire population of
America he in the end he would be in the
hole about two hundred and sixty seven
trillion dollars so he would probably
noticed that now if he were to
distribute his old net worth how much
could he give us this is a little bit
better he could give us all 180 dollars
so if he if he forfeited all of his
money we would all get 180 bucks and
that's that's not bad you know that's
that's you could you could do some
damage at Best Buy with 180 bucks or you
could go to the grocery store you could
buy easily six or seven boxes of
brand-name cereal with that kind of
money so that would be great the really
amazing thing here is because I'm never
surprised by the stupidity of one person
there is no amount there is no level of
stupidity that a person can sink to or
perhaps rise to that would surprise me
for an individual person I understand
that the capacity of an individual
person to be stupid is infinite
limitless but when the stupid thing
requires the planning and approval of
several other people then that's when it
becomes really mind-boggling so think of
how many layers of stupid were involved
in bringing this glorious moment to air
you had the original stupid tweet then
you had the woman there and and also
Brian Williams stupidly reading that and
not seeing the mathematical difficulties
then there had to be a graphics guy who
put it up there so it could go on air a
producer I mean easily we're talking
about at least five or six other people
on top of Brian Williams and the person
who tweeted it and the woman they're so
easily Fiverr said we're talking about a
total of like nine or ten people and
none of them all of them literate adults
all of them college-educated I assume
which only goes to my point about
college education by the way none of
them saw the problem with that but this
does at least clarify one thing it shows
why so many people in this country think
they should be given free everything
free college free healthcare free
housing and so on there's a very
clarifying moment it's because they
don't understand how numbers work if you
think that 500 million dollars can make
millionaires out of 327 million people
to just imagine what you think the
government can do with its four trillion
dollar budget imagine what it with now
that we understand that mentality the
the prominence the rise of socialism in
the United States starts to make sense
okay let's go to emails Matt well show
at gmail.com Matt while show at
gmail.com this is from Patrick says good
evening Matt first of all I need to
share my appreciation for you who you
are and what you do as a Catholic
conservative living in Massachusetts I
sometimes feel as if I'm surrounded by
madness Casca esque it doesn't begin to
describe the sensation so thank you for
being one of the few sources of sanity
and what can otherwise seem to be an
insane world with that important feature
out of the way would you mind explaining
what motivated your decision to get a
tattoo I've always mused about getting a
symbol of my faith as a tattoo and I've
heard some pros and cons but as a fellow
Catholic I'm curious what brought you to
decision to one get a tattoo to choose
the chiro as opposed to a cross or other
religious symbol and three put it on
your forearm thank you for your time and
for doing incredible work have yourself
a great evening well as far as the
tattoo goes you know I like the idea of
having a just a symbol of my faith that
would would be out on display for
everybody proudly it's also given rise
to many opportunities for conversations
with with with people non-christians
oftentimes when I'm out somewhere and
they'll say what's that tattoo about and
I'll explain it so that gives an opening
to talk about my faith so Ivan I've
enjoyed having it for that reason the
Cairo I just I I like the how ancient
the symbol is this is that this is the
symbol that was prominent before even
the the crucifix was a prominent
Christian symbol and so I like the
history of it and as far as on my arm I
I think what I was when I was getting
that tattoo tattoo and choosing that
location one verse that was in my mind
was verse and Song of Solomon that says
set me as a seal on your on your heart
as a seal on your arm for Stern as death
is love paraphrasing I might botch that
first a little bit but now obviously I
know that that verse is not referring to
a tattoo but still I saw I saw it as a
symbol of that now for the first thing
you said about knowing that you're not
alone when you're surrounded by madness
well that's the things that really we
aren't alone and there there are as sane
people also as Christians we're not the
only ones there are a lot of us out
there and and and so it's it's both
encouraging and discouraging for me I
was talking about this with someone
yesterday I was doing an interview for
the Church of cowards my new book which
is in stores now and I was talking about
this how it's sort of encouraging and
discouraging when I go out and I talk to
people and I discover all these many
people feel the same way that I do on
all these all these issues or I get
emails from people so that's the
encouraging part is knowing that I'm not
alone which is the feeling that you have
right but then also it's a little bit
discouraged because I think well there's
so many of us that are sane and rational
and have a have a clear moral sense
about so many of these issues then why
are things the way they are in the
culture we talk about the silent
majority and we say that proudly we say
that conservatives are the silent
majority well it's it's nice to know in
one hand that if we are the silent
majority that there's a majority but why
are we silent it just makes it all the
more pitiful and that goes to church of
cowards that's why I wrote the book that
were cowards that were the majority but
we've allowed this to happen I talked
the things I talk about all the time
with the drag queens and and the the
gender stuff
I absolutely believe I know that the
majority of people are not on board with
this yet it's happening and why is that
why are we letting this happen when we
have the numbers on our side I don't
want to hear anything about the elites
they have all the power no if we were to
rise up and speak out and actually use
our numbers to our advantage
this stuff would not
happening a drag queen story our
happening in a town where 90% the people
think it's crazy well if that 90% would
speak up and maybe get out of their
houses and off their butts and even show
up to the library to let their voices be
heard and to make it clear I think it
wouldn't happen I feel the same way when
I when I get emails if I'm talking about
some controversial subject and I takes a
position I'm getting a lot of backlash
you know I'll get all these private
messages and emails from people saying
hey I agree with you I agree with what
you're saying about I just want to let
you know thumbs up
keep it going and I think thank you for
the encouragement
why are you whispering it to me behind
the bushes okay why are you but why are
you saying we tell you something I agree
it's like I'm in the middle of a
pitchfork mob and they're bearing down
and then there's someone hiding behind
hiding behind hiding in an alley over
there and they were they they motioned
me over hey I agree with you
keep it up champ and then they run off
like well thank you but it may be
publicly if you say that that'd be kind
of nice I understand people have jobs
and things unlike me I don't have a job
so that's something you have to have to
factor in as well but but still yes I
guess my point is Patrick that were not
alone that there are a lot of us out
there which is encouragement but it's
also our shame that we have allowed the
culture to become what it is despite the
fact that most of us know it's wrong
let's go to Cuba Cuba I'm not sure if
it's with a KK you be a so most eminent
and sublime met my humble personage
bowels before your grandeur have you
heard of the song the man by Taylor
Swift if not you should watch it on
YouTube the song is so good at
portraying what a man is and does that I
figure that you might find some
inspiration and personally I've been
playing this song on repeat because it
speaks the truth of how a man acts in
many ways I fall short of the standard
outlined by Swift she makes an excellent
point when she states that I'm sick of
running as fast as I can
wondering if I'd get there quicker if I
was a man to that I say yes yes you
would be you would because men are built
physically faster built physically to
run faster what a wonderful insight okay
let me yeah I thought I'd played this
song on the air I'm sorry if I did
because it's such a wonderful song let
me play a quick clip of this it's a new
music video from Taylor Swift a song
called the man where she dresses up as a
man and is talking about trying to show
all the all the all the terrible things
that men are able to do so watch this
you can tell the song itself is just a
terrible song which is what we've come
to expect if Taylor Swift especially in
recent years but she dressed up as a man
we see here on a subway of course doing
the man spread with her with her legs
wide open yeah that's a man all right
that's a that's a men act all men right
and by the way as I've tried to explain
in the past I don't want to get into
graphic detail okay I'm not going to
give a whole anatomy lesson here but for
feminists that don't understand why men
don't sit the same way that women said
it's because we do have different body
parts which makes it so that we are
going to sit a little bit differently
from you but I wait so Taylor Swift's
got the man spread and she's got her arm
around as a man he's quote/unquote got
his his arm around the person next to
him and she's smoking a cigar on the
subway and then ashing out into a
woman's purse next to her and then she
comes out and she pees in the middle of
the subway station which that does
happen but usually it's the homeless
people doing that yeah some ways we see
it all the time on subway right the guy
a man smoking a cigar on the train
tapping the ashes into a woman's purse
totally normal
yeah but this is how feminists see men
this is as cartoon we work cartoons to
them and that's why they're so bitter
about men because they don't understand
a single damn thing about men now how do
you think that you think a male artist
could make a video like that about women
all of the annoying things women do you
think a man can get away with that well
the first problem is that the the song
would be way too long the song will be
six and a half hours long and nobody's
gonna listen that so that'd be the first
problem but nobody would he couldn't get
away with it only women can do that
finally this is from Sarah this telling
me this is this is the why I'm wrong
email of a day not the most important
issue in the world but you know you got
to keep me this is what I say but I
encourage the emails telling me why I'm
wrong and it doesn't have to be just you
got to keep me honest so if I make any
mistake at all in your mind let me know
and that's what Sarah's doing here says
dear Matt you are wrong about the fairy
godmother and the Cinderella reboot this
character will not be called the thing
as you postulated indeed they have
already determined the name of this
generalist being fab G the actor slated
for the genderless role Billy Porter
claimed quote it hit me when I saw on
the set last week how profound it is
that I am playing the
fairy godmother yes profound deeply
profound they call it the fab G magic
has no gender this is a classic fairy
tale for a new generation I think that
the new generation is really ready the
kids are ready
it's the grown-ups that are slowing
stuff down Sara continues I'm sure this
was an honest error on your part but
please be sure to tread a bit more
lightly on such serious topics going
forward fab G okay you got me on that
one I was wrong
doesn't happen often and it does give me
an idea for when my kids get older and
they have kids of their own I don't want
to be called grandpa I want to be called
fab G because when you see me it's the
first thing you think right is fabulous
you look up fabulous in a dictionary
you're gonna see my face and we'll leave
it there hope you guys all have a great
weekend by the book Church of cowards
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle well
tune in to the Ben Shapiro show we will
get a whole lot of that and much more
see you there